okay my name is Ian Cooper and what I
want to talk to you today is about micro
services and how I see a lot of people
using micro services defaulting to a
requester of an architecture and how
that requester of an architecture has
problems and how moving to an advantage
of an architect can solve many of those
problems for you this is a little bit
about me it's not particularly
interesting the only two takeaways that
I usually ask people to get from this
slide are one that I don't work for a
consultancy I currently work for a food
delivery internet-based service called
just E which skip the dishes in Canada
and so I don't have nothing to sell you
apart from kind of my experience the
other point I try and draw attention to
is the one at the bottom which is it can
get very easy at conferences to kind of
believe that people are standing up on
raised platforms the smart people we're
not really just like you just most
myself working people in the software
and you could be up here doing what I'm
doing and I understand it requires a
little bit of self confidence to get
there I got here really by accident that
when dotnet first started and about 2000
2003 are sort of the user group and
there was nobody to talk about dotnet
there was only really the even corporate
from Microsoft consent people so we had
to essentially say who's gonna talk next
week he's gonna pick a topic and
introduce there a whole other group to
this topic in now and that got me
through the hurdle of fear of standing
front people of speaking it had to do it
quite a bit so I'd like to just
encourage you that all of you could be
standing where I am and it is really
worth it and one of the things that
really helps you do is organize your
thoughts about a topic because you have
to essentially be the content the slides
is there to help and it helps you really
dig down into all the edge cases and
organize your thoughts and I've
encourage you all to have a go at
speaking how many developers in the room
okay how many Python developers in the
room okay
so I work on an open source messaging
library we have a dotnet version we have
a Python version and it's designed to
help you with connecting to various
transports like RabbitMQ SQS Kafka we've
only really got an alpha sh as your
service bus and we'd love to get some
help on that we are very welcoming as an
open-source community if you want to
come and work at open source we are
really happy to have new helpers and
there's usually choir or workaround in
preventing transports or support for
different databases on the platform we
are an alternative to mass transit so
it's probably bad known in the US and in
service bus which is a commercial
offering on the Python side I guess
where I'll turn to the celery we also
mapped as an alternative to mediator in
network if you want to use that well
it's what's our agenda today I'm going
to talk about this kind of journey from
monolith to micro services how we do it
I don't know labor at that point I'm
sure you've all seen a lot of talks
about that transition but what I want to
draw out is why we end up in a certain
kind of place that leads us to this
requester of an architecture so I want
to really talk about the problem of a
requester of an architecture where we
end up with really distributive monolith
now not really a proper microservices
architecture and talk about how people
try and throw containers and service
meshes that the problem is a China a
solution and then we'll look at a vent
talk about how events is actually a
better model in many cases and then
we'll talk a little bit actually about
reference data also we'll throw in some
discussion of pipes the pipes and
conversations they're they're the bit
that I find most people find challenging
about moving to an event-driven
architecture there's some stuff there
that's not widely talked about enough by
people who have experience and
event-driven architectures so sharing
that knowledge with you in a few terms
will help you go away and dig into them
a bit more buff yourself we may have
time for questions
nobody knows all right one of the things
to point out is that I occasionally in
this example are use examples from
imaginary piece of hotel software is
anyone here working Hotel software
awesome because I don't either
and I know nothing about it
unfortunately none of you or any wiser
that I'll have about my lies so that's
all very good Potter is no do it is so
that nobody here thinks I'm referring to
the mistakes of a previous employer
I can disguise for anybody everybody
behind me behind that platform and also
I find that the more like she know about
of a an area the harder is we could talk
about it without getting lost in the
detail so hopefully it's broad enough
stroke people can understand what I'm
trying to say alright let's talk about
typical model if the microservices
journey so there's really one major
reason to move towards micro services
and that is because your team has
outgrown a kind of two Pizza size as
Amazon would say there are now too many
of you to work efficiently your problem
is that essentially if you have just one
large code base with potentially
multiple teams working on it you're
going to have to figure out how you can
work in the same wrapper you're going to
have to produce feature branches when
you want bring those feature branches
back into the main line you're gonna
have to coordinate whose feature
branches are going into this release
once you've got all the features but
just what for this release added
together how we're gonna thank you a the
particular the product with all those
features now added into it do they
conflict with each other
somebody's product that feature doesn't
seem to work very well in that final
testing so the whole release is stalled
we roll that back out factually or do we
wait for them to finish we can't achieve
high velocity we can't achieve this
model which says we want continuous
delivery you complete work on a story
and essentially we check it into
production as soon as we can that's
creates a massive inventory waste
because we've done all this work but we
can't actually get value from it by
releasing it to our customers when the
management team comes to you and say we
want to go for us too often the solution
is to try and say how can we remove some
of its inefficiency from the release
process so the idea is we break up up
home into a large number of pieces so
that each team can essentially release
independently of the others and that's
why we tend to be distributed in this
model because it gives each team an
isolated piece of the platform that they
can release without dependences of
anybody else just to give you an example
just eat is about a thousand people
company you know that something like 700
our software engineers they buy that
over about 52 teams obviously a problem
for us would be if we've got 52 teams
working on a single codebase releasing a
software would be a nightmare so we try
and move towards a model where
effectively we divide the software into
52 pieces to give each team the
emergency release independently this is
quite often known as the inverse
Conway's law maneuver because Conway's
law says that as any architecture is a
reflection of the structure of the
organisation that built it and so if we
say well we want to do therefore is try
and structure our architecture so that
we can support our organizational
structure then we actually may get
benefit in terms of the velocity and
speed that we're moving in and there
lots of other side benefits we get from
micro services we get a hybrid to reason
about our software reduce complexity of
what teams individually deal with but
many of those benefits are achievable by
simple componentization the driving
force for us to move to micro services
is we have multiple teams cooperating
together and that means something quite
interesting right we want effectively
stable boundaries because any consumers
of the api's that are micro services
produce we may actually decide that on
Microsoft's teams own the front end
components they get gathered together to
make up the actual mobile client or the
web clients many consumers of those API
are just able contract right they want
something that's going to remain fairly
consistent over time when one micro
service talks to another we're also
going to want to have relatively stable
contracts we want those api's to not
change every other day but
more like you know every six months or
so by gonna add the items so we need a
way of achieving those stable boundaries
how do we slice up and partition our
original large platform into pieces that
are stable so one useful model is called
business capabilities and business
capabilities essentially around the
concept of saying we would like the
partitions that our system has to
reflect the forces of change that the
product team will effectively be driving
into our software what we would like is
for any given product to that manager to
be able to say I need to create some new
features around a particular part of
what we our platform does and interact
probably with one team because
coordination across multiple teams is
hard work and the typical complaints you
get when you start to say what the model
I want is to have a team with strong
ownership of a given part of the
platform a given micro service is the
product team start complaining and
saying it was much easier when I simply
got a team of developers given to me to
build a feature and they could touch any
part of the codebase and the reason
they're complaining is because they they
constantly have to coordinate efforts in
multiple teams to get any feature out
but if we get good alignment on our
partitions between what the business
requires and what the team is actually
owns then we may find a greater number
of pieces of work and delivered by one
team on their own for that reason we
look at the thing called business
capability mapping and a business
capability is simply a way of breaking
up the things that an organization does
in order to deliver value to customers
typically you can use this modeling to
map an entire business and find out its
IT needs in our case we want to shift
the focus of how we do that slightly
probably to focusing on what our
platform our software platform we're
offering does and offers other
businesses so from say just each
perspective we are building a platform
that connects restaurants to customers
to delivery partners we are essentially
offering services that those particular
groups of people in order to help them
work together and that's our platform
those are the services were offering see
we we usually divide business
capabilities in three kind of levels you
can keep going down you can go four or
five six we essentially decompose your
business from the top down so everybody
has these things called foundational
capabilities that we drives into
operational environmental so operational
or how we actually do stuff for our
customers how we make products and how
we shouldn't because we sell them to
them and environmental capabilities are
those things that we kind of have to
have as a business to support all those
functions like you know Human Resources
for example or lawyers to talk to the
regulator's if we drop down to level
three which is more level two for a
second business capabilities are things
that we actually offer services to the
customers generally you will find that
but sure enough business already knows
what the kind of capabilities they have
are so a couple of classic examples one
would be there's a thing called lead
generation and lead generators what
marketing departments do and they do
that in order to fill basically a funnel
of us for sales teams to go and get
basically potential leads that they can
phone up or go and visit to sell your
products to them and most salespeople
will expect that your marketing
department does lead generation it is a
thing it is fairly consistent than most
in departments do that so we know that
lead generation is a stable idea at a
time right
our marketing for if we're building a
platform does marketing it's probably
gonna need to have some cake some part
of it which does the lead generation the
process both lead generation is done is
unstable it may change over time in
other words the implementation of a
micro service but about the lip not
about lead generation would change over
time as you've got better ideas about
how to do it but our platform will
always need to be able to offer a lead
generation capability so that gives us a
stable boundary to partition on
and it gives us a boundary that the
product team would understand because
they were to say we're building a
marketing platform
we're gonna need lead generation oh I've
got this great new idea I've written an
article basically about better ways of
doing lead generation I'd like to infer
support for that and I for us one team
intends to be dealing with that we go
back up one we get to a capability group
so capability group of singers that have
like a similar outcome okay and often
you'd find in a business that what
happens is there is some departmental
head who is accountable probably to the
board for delivery of that function so
lead generation typically belongs to
marketing so marketing is probably a
capability group right because the
results of marketing effectively are
generally generated basically contact
with customers from sales and typically
actually what happens is that capability
group marketing and sales is one
capability very front okay well
organizing okay so as an example here's
Molly yes but what you might find inside
a platform designed to help hotels
market their services so we've got
something called rooms for example rooms
were deal with basically the booking of
rooms reservations management of the
rooms in our state's you know the kind
of things that basically say my hotel
consists of a lot of rooms market sales
are marketing a bit the bit with a bit
that sells those rooms to individual
customers right puts them out on Expedia
and says effectively okay please buy my
room is decides on pricing organizes
promotions but about the service food
and beverage so we provide basically
room service break first that kind of
thing cetera through our customers we
may have some things to do with
purchasing receiving because we have
other stuff going in and out of our
hotel right we've got some environmental
processes like accounting and
potentially legal and compliance
engineering probably deals with
basically maintaining the rooms their
security provides may see much for the
guests are safe right it's a guess right
but you can see the car
level we're dealing with and so you can
break that down one level and then we
might say we're now rooms capability
then what we may well have is some parts
of our rooms capability that deal with
things like housekeeping front office
booking etc we can put that down one
level again and we could look at say our
front office and our reservations when
what the to tell you our
reservation sections get divided on
direct bookings bookings for large
accounts channel management which will
be about effectively our ability to
communicate with say booking.com or
Expedia about the availability of rooms
that we had for given dates right or
essentially front office would deal with
the check-in checkout process and those
are potentially stable boundaries for
our micro services okay
people often use the word boundary
context when they talk about basically
dividing up microservices family
contacts are useful there our concept
from domain modeling which says I want
to draw up a subset of my domain in
which a set of terms have a consistent
meaning so that if I use the word room
I'm gonna have a consistent meaning for
room in that context and it's gonna have
a set of properties that relate to the
things that I'm doing with the room but
the problem might be that room is such a
generic term in our business that it has
many meanings individual departments
engineering they feel differently about
room - housekeeping - reservations right
reservations may care about offering you
a king-sized bed and a shower and a
cable or whatever actually whereas
engineering may care about what kind of
shower got installed in that room etc
okay we can do under our state up to say
rather than have a room that has 400
properties in each era we have a room
that has the properties that it needs so
that reduces the complexity of our
modelling generally speaking a business
capability will be at least one bounded
context so we say at least one it will
probably be a
domain that is understood by the people
working in that area of the business to
have certain meaning for terms that they
use occasionally you financially get
multiple domains inside of seeing the
capability so how do we how do we go
about this process of Croteam
micro-services so I've got a model with
right what I do is I essentially had
done waves at my partitioning exercise
and I found what I believed to be my
candidate microservices and then a
typical process I use is I said she'd
say right let's take that's the slice
all the code that deals with that
particular capability and we'll copy it
into a new solution or a vector or a new
set of folder structure files there's
gonna contain basically all of the code
that writes that partition and that
exercise may involve a certain amount of
shuffling right because it may not have
been a clear slice of my original
monolith clear vertical slice and so I
may have to essentially juggle a few
bits together to try and make a decent
vertical slice and you might end up with
at the same time thinking well I could
improve my tests I could get you know
some better layering in and get a clean
architecture model it may be a little
tiny bit of improvement rather than
effectively rewriting generally speaking
what you want to do this put in time
though is keep the code functionally
pretty much the same because you're
gonna be running both this service and
the model if at the same time talking to
the same database so you want the impact
of cooling it to have the same effect
and then what you do is you say write
I'm going to put an API over that micro
service well here's how maybe I brought
of most cases many of you will
understand an HTTP API but any kind of
API would do events or something else
right and why it's important we'll come
back to you later and what I say is that
effectively all the calls that used to
go into the monolith now have to be
redirected to go through my micro
service and eventually the only writes
to the tables essentially
associated with that particular
partition will come from my new micro
service the code that essentially is in
the original monolith will no longer be
right into those tables at that point I
can move those tables into my new micro
service and say I now own that data and
typically I call that point autonomy
because it means I should better ship
that code on its own ok
and you may have to do some work at that
point this current will come to in a
minute
to deal with what happens with pieces of
the Moral if that wants it to read
information from those tables and we'll
come back to them in a second but the
idea is that nothing in my service here
now needs to talk to the monolith
database and essentially we just rinse
lather and repeat with that process
right keep taking slices out until our
monolith breaks down starting quite
often with what we might think of as our
core capabilities the most valuable ones
that our customers like the ones that
essentially the product team are always
basically generating new features for
and working on words or supporting
services and actually that can take a
long time because the supporting
services can be very difficult to
finally get over the line because
there's not so much impetus to change
them ok here's where the thing that's
tend to start to go wrong in that
process imagine I've got some code looks
like this and in my code eventually one
of the things that originally I did when
I took a booking was to make a call to
payments like a payment for the booking
what do I transfer my code into its own
little micro service for my bookings
service I come across the problem that I
don't have payments code in my micro
service anymore it lives somewhere else
in a payments micro service so my
booking micro service I'm trying to make
a payment school how do I do that
right how am I gonna make that payment
so we tend to have and reach for a
simple answer and the simple answer is
hey well my credit card payment services
got a lovely HTTP API and I'm gonna make
a call to that or at the same time I can
make a call to housekeeping to tell them
about this reservation so that they'll
book and get the room ready in time
again all right all cool channel
management so they decrement the count
of the number of rooms that are
available so we don't overlook the hotel
and that solution seems easy because I'm
quite often able to write some simpler
anti-corruption layer around basically
an HTTP call and I can kind of hide from
the programmer that in fact they're
doing that in the first place they just
continue making that self dot payments
called and under the hood we're doing
this HTTP call right by requests or
whatever okay we've now introduced some
problems that we didn't have with the
monolith the first one of them is called
temporal coupling temporal coupling is
the property that two services need to
be available at the same time for
something to work if my channel manager
goes down
I now have felt take the booking
particularly if I've kind of hidden from
the software developer the fact that
he's actually now making a remote call
and it's kind of like reimplemented that
original local call was looking like
something remote using G RPC or whatever
the programmer may be completely unaware
that a call to channel manager could
fail because Challenger is down and I
can't take any bookings and the question
is is that what the business really
wanted to happen were there really so
concerned that they might get over
booking through Expedia they don't take
any bookings right now because the
channel management is down probably not
generally speaking if you ask the guys
running the hotel what should happen at
this point they'd say we're okay with
over bookings people don't show up and
if they do show up we have an
arrangement with another hotel down the
road it doesn't get as many bookings we
can put our overflow into that other
hotel
so that's fine if it turned out that the
channel manager was down we could
actually be ignored that guy's sorry you
didn't know that we've missed all those
bookings we lost millions but what does
it matter okay
so just eat take something like I think
2,000 orders a minute I don't think this
is MD at all and when parts of the
service are down it gets very expensive
very fast if we had a dependency on
another service between something taking
an order and something essentially that
basically relates to that order flow and
we said we can't take orders right now
because this bit of the system we can't
talk to it you can get into millions of
pounds of losses in a very short time
window and we're a publicly traded
company and shareholders ask awkward
questions the other thing we have is
called behavioral coupling so got this
lovely model that's calling channel
management and calling housekeeping etc
all right
and let's say we're doing really well as
a company and we started to on board
more teams to move faster and it turns
out one of the things that all of our
customers want is more housekeeping
functionality I don't know why but okay
they want more housekeeping
functionality and so we basically hire
some more teams and we say well hang on
a minute
help these teams move fast we're gonna
have to partition housekeeping you know
what we're going down to the level for
rather than level three my decomposed
housekeeping some more but the problem
now is that direct booking was calling
housekeeping and I've suddenly turned
that into cleaning laundry and inventory
and the problem with this is that in
order to basically release those new
services I'm gonna have to tell direct
bookings that you don't longer calling
housekeeping you're calling cleaning and
laundry and whatever that's kind of a
problem because I don't want to have to
basically re-release direct bookings and
tell that team you've got to this whole
little work about shooting out
these new services and all we're gonna
have this grand switchover day away and
suddenly we're not using housekeeping
anymore we're using these new other
services and don't worry it will be fine
I'm sure we won't lose the platform for
any period of time and customers can't
book into our hotel and sometimes these
seem like kind of unresolved or problems
but other times you think there may be
their solutions right so one of the big
solutions today is the service machine
the problem in terms of temporal
coupling right so we say it's okay we're
using HTTP api's we know how the web
works and the web goes to really high
scale right and the web solves this
problem it just basically uses a kind of
proxy model so effectively we have a
whole load of upstream web versions of
instances of channel manager and
housekeeping and credit card payments we
slip in behind a proxy and the proxy
basically does some load balancing to
all the upstream instances and then
essentially we can just throw instances
at this problem you know we can be
running hundreds of instances in Amazon
even by the cost or making a lot of
money right surely that would be fine
and we could push basically all requests
out to them and you know what things I'm
here there are some advantages I get
right now everything's going through a
proxy upstream service I can do health
checks and the health checks are tell me
which one of these instances are
actually up and running so I can make
sure direct like a direct booking calls
to healthy instances of my back in
service I'm really solving the problem
and however the temporal coupling and
you know what well I'm here sings I'm
going through a proxy well maybe it's
just a temporary network outage causing
me a problem so my proxy could do a
retry oh hell you know what happens if I
see this thing is really down I could
just do a circuit breaker and I could
say you can't get to that right now and
what I'm gonna do all this maybe I could
divide my actual whole thing into a data
planar control plane right and my
control plane is gonna say well I could
do some service discovery for you you're
doing basically the RPC now aren't you
so you know
well the proxy will do is tell you where
all the services are al-qadir monitoring
its
learn through our product proxy so the
proxy can be the point of which you mark
to how that what healthy our overall
system is and you can put some
configuration here as well because you
don't have to have that in all the
individual files because you know what
that relates to something quite dynamic
about the topology of our system and you
know at the same time maybe effectively
we can put some policy decisions in the
here right and service measures are
really either way essentially you get
workable RPC systems you know they're
just the same thing as basically a cobra
request broker they got a fancy name
because they want because because
effectively vendors want to sell you the
same old stuff with a new name on it but
as much is not new as much it's just a
corporate request broker with a fancy
new name on the top to make you feel
like you buy something shiny you've just
built essentially 1990s architecture
congratulations and part the problem is
when we when we had this kind of idea of
micro services there was a was a goal
called basically small endpoints and
dumb pipes um how I did the time so
brief kind of segue so micro services
comes from a guy called Jim Weber
essentially and Jim Weber effectively
created a thing called guerrilla SOA
people were doing SOA and the vendors
got their pause in the middle and they
started by spiking issues things like
enterprise service bus --is BizTalk
slap-bang anyone use best talk they want
a love biz talk okay
and they've got they put these things in
the middle of the process they made a
whole situation very complicated and Jim
just said you know what services are
easy you just basically build a explicit
boundary around the work that you're
doing that's suppose some contract that
people can call and go for it sick all
that work broke a light rabbit in the
middle if you need a broker or just do
HTTP API light if you need to write the
whole idea was to get away from heavy
centralized resources controlled by
operations teams owned by vendors that
are locked us into a particular platform
but the vendors don't like that right
because we're escaping their clutches so
the throne so smashes at us and then our
re badge es visas event meshes so what
went wrong
because I still have a super team on
earth right I've just gotta do a
reliable the super team one of the
thanks to my service mesh and there was
a better way it's just no one told you
probably so there's a choice that we're
essentially making a lot when we build
software and that's whether we really
got a favor consistency or availability
right and originally cap theorem was
really focused at databases and it's
focused at the idea that if I had a
database supported by multiple nodes
there was a risk that there'd be a
partition in other words the nodes
couldn't talk to each other over the
network generally they're short outages
but if you run particularly public
infrastructure at the clare by AWS or as
you see them quite a lot you seem less
on data centers where effectively your
network is about this long okay and the
idea is when there's a network partition
I get one or two choices I can be
consistent in other words I shut down
the nodes that are in the in the
minority half of the partition I've got
three for example one of them is the
partition I shut down that node there
the other to continue to give service in
service because these two can remain
consistent they can keep asking each
other what the date of what the state
the data is now right or availability
I'll let you access any of the nodes but
we accept that no you may be talking to
nodes in a in a stale portion of our
network for a period of time so you're
really always choosing between
consistency over team and when micro
service is it's a pretty similar story
Norway that if all these micro services
are communicating I kind of get to
choose right do I want to enforce
consistency I must be able to get the
answer from this other micro service in
real time or don't want to choose
availability I'm okay with subsidies
having having stale data from that other
micro service to service you instead and
events are gonna let us do the latter
and I'll explain what how in a second
so the model really comes down to this
what I'm taking my booking is it
important that I can talk to
housekeeping right well can I
essentially the disregard the fact that
I can't talk to housekeeping right now
so my story is of actually the you know
I've had this experience but checked
into a hotel so you stir with my not my
current pot and my ex-wife used to
basically once a year we'd go to a
really fancy hotel for the night just
kind of live like the other half did
right we went to a fancy hotel called
the Dorchester and it's about $500 a
night we turned that basically and they
said I'm exceptionally sorry mister Mrs
Cooper but your room is not ready and
we're like oh and what money for this
room what's going on right and then they
said please don't worry about it go to
the bar and drink whatever the expensive
alcohol is that we have available at the
Dorchester are just drink as much as you
want until your room is ready
so about three or four hours for our
rooms be ready but you know what we
didn't really care and so generally
there are processes in mature businesses
to deal with issues of lack of
availability or consistency particularly
if they had a pre alternation process
Amazon does this all the time with you
try and buy an item it turns out it
wasn't really in stock there's a process
they sends you an email right and
actually I'm using quite a likes it
because that's customer interaction and
my chance to offer you some service the
other option basically is to say I'm
going to favor availability so even if
housekeeping is down I'll just
effectively figure out a way to maybe
tell housekeeping later doesn't matter
right now and take your booking there's
no housekeeping service I want I will
fit I'll pick it up with housekeeping
later all right
so better model is going to be for us to
use events at this point to make this
change how does this work
okay so I direct booking service stars
when it gets a booking it raises an
event out to a broker a tribe mq or
kefka or SQL or SNS rather or or a zero
service bus and it raises an event and
it publishes basically to a logical
channel and logical channels you can
think of as having like a
topic or a name and we just say hey
there is a book he made and other
services downstream subscribe to that
idea right
so housekeeping says yes I want to
subscribe to booking made events and
when I receive one I will take action
and I will do whatever housekeeping
needs to do as a response to that the
advantage of this process is as follows
let's imagine that channel manager is
not available throughout booking doesn't
care he's just raising its events it
doesn't know whether effectively the
channel manager is currently working or
not and what happens with events is we
basically rely on something called
guarantee delivery so generally when we
subscribe to a topic we have a Q the Q
simply stores up the events for us and
to the point we're ready to read them
but I could kind of an answer machine
right so channel manager basically just
takes the events and stacks them up you
can often think about basically work by
the way interactions in terms of
services by basically any phone calls
right I'm gonna know no one makes phone
calls anymore but never mind
but once front of it but my mum phones
me but apart for me when you find
something on the phone right they're not
there it's a frustrated experience I got
a busy tone or whatever right I can't
call you I can't make the things happen
right but back in the day you'd leave a
message right hey you can action this at
whatever I'm talking to you about later
now we just send the text or whatever
but it's the same principle so in
channel manager comes back online
channel manager says great I can process
those events
now it's possibly there's a window in
which we got overbooking as a result of
that we are essentially eventually
consistent with the booking system but
it's probably a process we have to cope
with that as far did we think about our
business process we can generally tend
to basically support eventual
consistency and the other advantages
because I'm just raising events and
anyone can subscribe to it I don't give
a damn what the topology the rest of the
system looks like from the point of view
of my team you want to turn housekeeping
into a set of different services
it doesn't matter to me he just new
subscribers I don't know who's
subscribing I don't really care who's
subscribing
turns out you want to make housekeeping
cleaning and laundry you do it just
release it on your own
subscribe to my events not a problem to
me so I can break both temperament
behaviour cutlery trivially with events
that's what it's there for
okay and the price is essentially only
that eventually I have to accept some a
latency I have to accept what we call
eventual consistency between these two
parts of my system there may be some lag
because I have to process the messages
in the queue or maybe down and come back
back up again and I'm coping with that
fact I've essentially saying what are
gonna get those messages later but
generally you know eventual consistency
is a feature or a lot of systems anyway
even if I'm calling you are actually to
be API is there's a latency involved in
the date when it leaves your API is
style okay so there are a couple of
little things that basically trip people
up when they're trying to understand how
event-driven outages work and so what it
is to do is cover a few of those to try
and help answer some of the most
frequent problems that I see okay so the
problem is let's say that when I take a
direct booking its a booking on account
so rather than being a guest piece of
information we're essentially the guest
has included all their credit-card
details etc actually it's an account
based booking and that information is
something they've already stored for you
so you don't have to keep adding it
every time basically make a booking with
me so what does credit card payments do
right now because credit card payments
has got a notification that a booking
has been married but it needs the
account information in order to actually
take your credit card payment the
problem is if I decide that the answer
to that problem was to make a call to
accounts I push myself back into a
requester of an architecture so now the
fact that accounts to be down temporal
coupling has emerged to bite me again so
all my effort and putting event-driven
architecture the boss
you told me this event-driven
architecture thing was going to
basically mean we didn't care about
about other services being down and now
it turns out I can't wait direct
bookings if the account service is not
up for anyone who holds an account they
have to kind of log in via the guest
system that's really annoying for them
to follow that process so what can I do
to fix this problem so there are a
couple of solutions that we can think
about so down in the lower left hand
side one thing is simply to include the
information with the original message
right to say when I basically make a
booking and the information goes to
credit card payments I will include all
the credit card details etc audience
right it's obvious how to do that for a
guest account because they've entered
that information it's a little bit less
obvious how to do that for an existing
account I'll cover that in a second
right but I can include the information
and then each process the whole booking
because you've got all the information
contained inside it the other mechanism
is to say credit card payments has a
copy of the account data and it can just
read that and it can read your credit
card information straight out of that
error that that database well we might
say but hang on a minute Microsoft's is
supposed to own their own data and no
one's supposed to look inside my
database and when it's following yeah
but this is just a cash it's a read-only
copy of somebody else's data and again
was playing that in a second all right
let's dig into these ideas a little bit
closer sort of our first option is to
remember that messaging support to cut
pipes and filters approach so I can
raise my kind of direct booking made and
I can listen to it somewhere else before
I pass it to credit card booking so
let's say in fact rather than a direct
booking made I just raised instead to
basically an account booking made my
account booking married since she
doesn't have the credit card information
inside it the account system listens for
that and it says Oh somebody's made a
booking under account I don't need to
add the credit card information to that
booking so that somebody else can
process that downstream and the account
system raises basically then an event to
say hey I've added the credit
information so there's now basically add
a booking made looking on account made
and credit card payment assistance to
that event and says great I've got the
credit card information and I can
essentially process the request and the
whole time I'm moving over events which
have guaranteed delivery so if anything
breaks temporarily it doesn't matter
because essentially eventually I will
get to the point of delivering that
message to the next person downstream so
I was safe from temporal coupling I do
have a certain amount of coupling in the
sense that the message has to flow
through a given pipeline and so
essentially I have some kind of implicit
workflow built into this model another
option is to say well rather than build
their implicit workflow into basically
what we would call choreography between
various microservices maybe I want
something to take control of the process
of filling in the data so that goes
downstream except ibly and I'll create
something called a conversation and
allocates probably something called a
saga which essentially says so Accord
and of state machine will drive the
process of making a booking and it will
run basically the booking through the
various steps and each step it will ask
a different service to you know add data
to the message process the credit card
payment etc typically these are nowadays
considered part of the API gateway layer
and they're one of those that people
attribute to things called a BFF our
back-end for front-end so bffs tend to
be associated more with building an API
that's tailored to a given client but
they also can do orchestration for you
across your micro services because they
expose essentially the booking API and
then effectively you make a series of
calls to implement that booking to your
individual micro services allowing your
micro services to basically have more
limited api's so the API gateway can
simply say great register direct booking
for me please
okay great and by the way but using the
pipe symbol to indicate this is a
message rather than basically require
just about that Clara on the diagram so
there are two pipes because I'm sending
a request on one channel and I'm
receiving a response on the other
channel right so a message and you can
do request response you just use two
channels right and generally what tends
to happen is when they send the request
I put the reply channel in the header of
the request please reply to me on this
channel so the command goes out and the
receiver says okay great I've got the
command in oh I'm gonna reply on the
channel
oh here's the correlation ID maybe just
so you can you can match the two up if
you need to and then essentially I could
call accounts and say hey we're gonna
need the credit card booking details
because this one came in on an account
it wasn't a basically a guest booking so
I'm going to push it through this routes
and probably with the one that's
basically a guest booking I'm pushing it
straight to the credit card payments
okay so get us a request response to
send a request message over a channel at
some point effectively what happens is
account will respond and send a reply
message based on this response channel
because I'm using channels that are sent
to your Q's doesn't matter if it's if
Senshi accounts is down for a period of
time right essentially all that happens
is I just wait until account wakes up
and it starts to issue responses back
over to sponsor my workflow probably
needs to be something I can save to a
database so that I can wake it up and
say okay you've reached the next stage
move your state machine on and
essentially add the credit card
information on what's the next step
right so generally you use something
some kind of state machine so in L and
eat something like stateless or the
wonderful mass transit I can never
pronounce Auto autonomous or something
like that effects etc or you can build
one yourself right a state machine that
you can say Eve to have given around the
database what happens is you say said my
first event go to sleep get the response
back wake up moving to the next state
ascend my next event in the workflow
wait for a response when the response
comes in waiting the up right and the
whole process is asynchronous and
doesn't depend on anything being up at
any given time is that eventually it
works the final option then what
happened is basically essentially
telling the real question to the credit
card and get a response back and
obviously the response might include at
some point in error I needed it too so
orcas are very good at managing error
flows okay
mostly you've probably seen those two
before you may not necessarily have
understood the use of sagas to basically
manage the amount of dose that needs to
flow through the system okay and the
next option is called reference data
from a paper by Pat Holland called data
on the inside versus data on the outside
so we think about a micro service there
are a number of things to understand
about it right it essentially says it
has an explicit bounds like a black hole
inside of my implementation details
please don't try and reach in and touch
those in it allowed to okay but I is the
owner at the Micra service can change
those to my heart's content so no you're
not couple to them get depend on them
you depend on the API be there events or
basically HTTP orgy RPC that's where
your dependency lives and I guarantee
you that will be stable right
I share schema not type in other words
basically I recognize that I might have
a platform that includes dotnet Java
Python go whatever so I'm going to share
some schema like Jason or Avro or
protobuf because they're
platform-independent formats and my
service is autonomous all by that I mean
is because I can control all of the
interior and you don't depend on it
I can release myself without worrying
about impacting anybody else you don't
talk to my database so I can change the
schema right doesn't matter you're not
impacted you only care about the
boundary by the way I'm Microsoft's is a
logical definition not a physical one a
given micro service may be influenced by
a number of processes webs where process
a worker process a database etc right
don't confuse the logical idea of micro
service with a physical single process
running in your application ok my micro
service effectively though can be
queried
so data does actually leave the event
horizon right I can do a get for example
to my HTTP API what I'm going to get
back is and basically dota there
represents for example a booking right
and when we subtly let me do a get so
one of the things we may choose to do is
say well how how current is they get
that the last four dates are I got from
you right so when you give me a get you
quite often give me a last modified re
tag
you say this is the current state of
this particular resource at this time
and you can also put on your HTTP header
you can put if modified since or I if
match or an e-tag right so you can say
do I have the current version of this
and if you don't if you do you got a 304
back and if you do I just give you if
you don't give you the copy the new
resource right so you can cache you can
cast yet locally to your application and
that's how the web scales by caching
right I only have one writer of my data
the doctor that I publish is immutable
there's no point in you trying to change
it you can't change the copy of doctor I
haven't side right it's stale as soon as
it leaves my application it's
potentially out of date because somebody
else had come in and through my API and
post a new a change to the booking and
the data that you just got five seconds
ago potentially out of date so it's
version that's all we have that if
modified since header a right for
example okay and the events just the
same event could have a version on it or
a timestamp because how old the do't
you've received in the event is okay so
the data inside are micro-service we
call inside data the data outside our
microsomes we call outside data and what
I can do is I can simply store that
outside data in a local cache to my
service so my credit card payment
service can essentially have a cache of
data that you've published from the
account service about what currently
counts are in terms of credit cards
except your information and I can then
use that to take bookings okay for you
to publish that they are outside it's
okay for me to cache it that's how the
web works there are many ways to
basically transfer that data we're going
to talk in a second about this one ECS T
event care estate transfer but older
school technologies include atom right
so you get atom feed so basically
they're just I do a get through an HTTP
feed which consists of a number of atom
entries right isn't
for news feeds right each one of those
entries can represent essentially the
change in the state of an entity in the
source system it was updated it was
deleted it was a new one was created
right Adam Fitz have a fantastic
property and that's that pages in the
feed are immutable
after beyond the first or current page
so when I asked for that page 13 it's
always going to have the same entries on
it that makes it really easy for a
consumer to read an atom feed and catch
up because they simply walk back to the
feed until they see that until the first
first page they haven't got they haven't
seen everything on find the first entry
they haven't seen and then will go back
up to the basically to them to the most
current entry so I can actually sit so
heavily cached it's very easy for me to
look for changes that I need to
basically apply to my local database
right particularly after the perimeter
of your organization if you deal with
partners who need to effectively
understand and cache current state of
events in of your system atom feeds are
a fantastic solution ETL right I can
similarly ETL the data between two
databases there are problems with this
to do with basically the fact that I'm
now coupling schema and also I need to
need to know it had the same technology
on both sides of the fence but huge
numbers of investment banks particular
city of London have used this approach
for years to replicate data throughout
the organization that is read-only for
one system and was rightful for another
okay you can even do FTP like an FTP
data for it's particularly slow moving
into a file system nowadays this looks a
bit more quite often I like writing
something basically to a blob storage in
s3 okay just eat many data moves very
very slowly Russians don't change their
menus much so we quite often share it by
simply publishing it to s3 as a blob and
let people read from there all right so
thank Karen state transfer st. Clair
state transfer says the source system I
love producing notifications about state
changes to entities it has if I listen
to the events representing their changes
to the entity
I can similarly update a cache that has
my local copy of the entity so I can use
the messaging system because I get
guaranteed delivery to listen to the
messages from upstream and build my own
local reference cache so now credit card
payments by listening to upstream
messages and writing them through its
own database has a copy of the upstream
account data that it can use to process
basically credit card payments okay
the credit card payments in turn or
probably raise events to say hey I said
got a credit card payment that another
downstream consumer might listen to to
build its own information about payments
made or booking they use to update
effectively its status right so just all
events well that tends to mean as we
when we talk about our micro service
decomposition we quite often have a
model well through down cut and shunt an
asset capture well we say hey maybe to
solve this problem sometimes that we get
when we're building micro service
breakdown so what happens to all those
tables that I used to call from my
booking service that are still in the
monolith I can do I can basically say
well why don't i source of vents out the
monolith to represent the state of those
tables they used to reach directly into
i give this place to make a cache of
them in my system and talk to them there
as though they were local to me and
typically we use things like triggers on
a database table or scraping an audit
trail and we simulate events being
generated out of their out of the
monolith and build a cache so now this
process of basically doing the cut and
shut becomes much easier because I have
a solution for all the things I used to
grab read-only from other parts of the
monolith where before I have to figure
out how am I going to get hold of those
in the future world while I'm still
translating some of these things into
new services while I don't have my
complete suite of services and I'm still
out on the marble having some other
functionality
I can force them into events I can
capture those events downstream I can
have a cache therefore of that data and
I can read that you like I always used
to and it helps us basically with an
interim step in our transfer of modulus
to micro services so reference data is a
key part of what one of me okay one last
piece I don't quite happened over time
let's look I'm close right okay
the reality is in some cases we actually
are not so I can't think of the word but
but so determined that we virtually have
either requests or events that we say
you know death to anyone using requests
reality is most real systems quite often
have a hybrid approach between these two
so imagine that when I take a direct
booking I want to take credit card
payments and I also may want to
basically I know send a respond to the
customer some offers like hey while
you're in in st. Paul why don't you
basically hire a car or wasn't you book
our fancy restaurant in hotels tend to
do and I might say well it's really
important to me that I complete the
payment process
I don't effectively lose your booking so
I'm going to do that bar events right I
raise a direct booking event I'm
skipping
potentially putting it sort of the
accounts here let's assume it's a guest
booking of all the credit card details I
take your credit card payment eventually
if it fails I was raised and other
events to say it failed and you updated
stations the booking but I want to
preserve that that's going to happen
okay but offers I may not care if offers
is down I may just say you know what
don't send the customer and it offers
the office service is currently not
running it's not critical to my business
I'm not losing vast amounts of money I'm
losing a little bit probably from some
commission I get from the other
companies by directing traffic to them
right so in that case because I'm
prepared for that particular flow to
file all these are a question of an
architecture for so usually you're
trying to make smart decisions any parts
of your process that you require to be
reliable in other words available to the
customer you tend to be to build an
event-driven architecture any parts of
your system where you don't require that
reliability and what actually you may
care more about is now consistency you
can build by requests so just eat for
example it's looking at I think the idea
of saying according to what the weather
is outside you may change your mind
about what foods you want to buy and I
may prioritize those differently on a
menu right so it's a consequence if I
turn around and that obviously requires
some consistency with what's the weather
look like right now it's no good me
saying or the weather about in the UK is
definitely not and he could be saying
well it's weather five hours ago because
it's probably different over here I
guess your weather may be stable for a
longer period of time but I'm in the UK
you know it's wait wait if you as you
get new weather right okay so the
reality is probably hybrid but the thing
I wanted to really draw to your
attention is people are essentially
building requestor of an architecture
sort of default for micro services and
you really need events as part of your
toolkit otherwise you're going to suffer
too heavily from temperature and
behavior or coupling to build an
effective architecture does what that
gives you the benefits that Microsoft
has promised you all right so I think
it's pretty much time so I don't have
time I don't think for a particular
questions but feel free to come and find
me at the end and ask the question I'll
be around in the conference next couple
of days they're more than happy for you
to kind of like you know badger me ask a
question
I am I Cooper on Twitter and my DMS are
open so feel free to basically just ping
me a DM as well okay all right thanks so
much
[Applause]